mj rodriguez joins us now at the table
because she got something to say
that's your new song we'll play a little
bit about that in just a second but
congrats number one congrats because you
are making history in so many ways and
you said that you were an emotional
wreck when you got the emmy nomination i
was tell us about that yeah so i was
stayed up completely until like 10
o'clock in the morning in the south of
france because i didn't know if what
time it was going to come out um i was
like i might as well record this
whatever the outcome may be i want to
save this as a memento and i remember my
mom just hugging me and i was screaming
when we found out oh here it is here it
is
yeah where are you i was in um
there you are
but you know what i appreciate i
appreciate that you say that you were up
watching because so many people say oh i
was sleeping they had to wake me up
there were so many texts i loved that
you were up watching because this meant
a lot to you it did it did i wanted to
uh i wanted to be a part of change and i
wanted people to see
us as five dimensional people versus
just caricatures you know you called it
a life-changing moment just a minute ago
how would it how is it a life-changing
moment um
it's a life-changing moment when you
actually you know come from
humble beginnings you come from an area
that you would never think people would
see you and or even notice you and you
get to a space where people finally see
you for your art and not just for
outside of the person they get to see
you for your craft and that was so
life-changing for me because i had been
working as a working actress and a
singer for a long time so it was great
you're an inspiration now for others but
i'm curious who inspired you oh my mom
my mom is my biggest inspiration like
she's the person who infiltrated
womanhood in my life she's the one who
raised me like she's the one who just
really made sure that i was diligent in
my craft and who i am so she's the
biggest influence you also called it a
love letter to transgender kids i love
that what do you mean by that mj it's a
love letter to transgender kids because
i mean you know finally the door is
being broken down for girls like us and
young trans men out there too a lot of
trans men don't get a lot of light too
so i want to give a shout out to the
trans men out there but um we don't get
a lot of light and now we finally are
where the door is opening and it just
feels good and it's for them the next
generation is keys i know you have
kicked down the door wearing high heels
cute shoes too thank you you know you
know what elsa i'm fascinated about you
when i was watching the show i didn't
know you could sing and you can sing
sing you sang a couple of times during
the episode but the fact and the video
is great you've got something to say
tell us about your musical kurt you're
singing well that's because you've been
doing that for a while yeah that's been
my main goal for a long time it's been
my passion um and me virginia white neil
pogue and a guy named john parish we
came together and we wrote this amazing
song called something to say and regine
white from earth wind and fire yes yeah
okay yeah and i was just excited because
finally my dream had been coming to full
fruition i mean
there it is my performance
goes yes look at me i look good look
somebody on your team said uh j.lo watch
out i would okay drop the microphone
jayla watch out i never want to try the
queen i love miss jayla i love you kayla
but yeah i feel like this moment in my
life is a defining one because it just
hasn't happened so i'm thankful for it
so more music to come more music to come
definitely and a music video just
strapped so hopefully people
was your mom a big supporter of your
music yes she was the one who was like
now when it came to my music she was
manager mom she made it wow she's like
get up there and stay girl and make sure
you put that mic up to your mouth don't
play around i'm like okay mom i got you
well it's the third and final season of
pose it's over where does blanca sit
with you she's always where is she gonna
where
where will she sit with you as you move
forward in your career i think blanca's
always gonna have like a space in my
heart she's always on my right or left
shoulder you know cheering me on she she
inspired me a lot the words that came
off the pages of that show were really
beautiful so i'm thankful that you know
i was the vessel for that character and
now i can move on to others you're doing
something different now very different
yes tell us about that yeah comedy yeah
i'm working with maya maya rudolph in a
new show called loot and people get to
see me flexing my show called what call
what loot
by maya ex
i'm starring maya rudolph and um a
couple of other amazing amazing people
emmy nominated great writers and stuff
so i'm really really excited you have
comedy chops too i do i do america
hopefully they like it
she sings she dances she acts all right
mj rodriguez we're cheering you on emmy
night you got you now you got to decide
what to wear i always live to see what
people are going to wear on the red
carpet i haven't already set out in my
head it's just going to be a big old
surprise when i get up on the red carpet
all right all right
all right congratulations thank you
thank you for getting up early i know
what this is like it's fun
for one day yeah yeah yeah you're right
tony for one day
you can watch the 73rd prime time emmy
awards a sunday september 19th at eight
o'clock eastern five o'clock pacific
right here on cbs or on the viacom cbs
streaming service that's paramount plus